this episode is supported by nordvpn
head over to nordvpn.com
microcosmos to learn more about virtual
private networks and Internet Security
[Music]
the micro Cosmos is not always a
graceful space sometimes an organism
just needs to get around the way it gets
around even if that means looking like a
swimming elephant head with a truncated
snout at one end and a rat tail at the
other
those odd creatures are called botanids
single-celled eukaryotes with two
flagella that create that frantic
movement they belong to a group of
flagellated protists called
kinetoplastida and it was probably a
relief to James our master of
microscopes that the kinetoplastids he
found had two flagella if there was just
one flagellum he would be dealing with
the other half of the group The
tripanosomatids
the family tripana somatida is made up
entirely of parasites that like to
infect insects and plants but some like
tropanosoma cruzi the organism
responsible for Chagas disease can make
their way over to humans via their
insect hosts causing aches and fever and
swelling among a number of other
symptoms
there are some parasitic botanids but
those ones tend to be found in fish and
snails and the family relationship they
have with trypanosomatids is made
botanids a handy organism to have around
so that we can better understand the
diseases their relatives cause it's a
nice role for an organism that is
sometimes easy to miss against the
backdrop of the microcosmos like if we
hadn't shown you what bodnids look like
already and if we'd opened today's
episode with this scene would you know
what you were looking for
I know I would probably have assumed
they were the green almond-shaped
organisms just because their color in
strange shape makes them stand out so
much more and even in this scene where
there are so many more bodenids to see
they're just so secondary to the giant
rotifer picking away at their population
those other creatures are fascinating
and we've encountered them plenty of
times on our journey through the
microcosmos but you know what they don't
have that Bond nids and their fellow
kinetoplastids do
chainmail
yes chainmail but also fine not actual
chain mail botnids aren't decorated in
metallic Loops what they have is
actually something much more unique and
fascinating something that has changed
the way we see the molecules and
processes fundamental to life
kinetoplastids get their name from this
unique chainmail structure it's called
the kinetoplast and it's found inside
their mitochondrion the kinetoplast is
unique but its building blocks aren't
it's just DNA you know that double helix
found in all of us that molecule that
holds the instructions for how our cells
look and behave when scientists were
finally able to see the kinetoplast
under an electron microscope they
realize that the DNA inside of it does
something kind of funny it forms
thousands and thousands of tiny little
circles along with around 25 to 50
larger circles and those circles of DNA
link together building a structure that
in many kinetoplastids looks a lot like
chainmail
scientists have done all sorts of
experiments to learn more about this DNA
but one of the most important things
they've learned isn't about DNA it's
about DNA single-stranded cousin RNA
we said earlier that DNA is like the
instruction manual that tells our cells
what to do but an instruction manual is
just a stack of paper if no one is
around to read it so inside of cells
there's a mechanism in place to read
that DNA transcribing it into a
single-stranded genetic material called
messenger RNA you can think of that RNA
as like someone reading aloud from the
instruction manual after that messenger
rna's words gets translated into action
producing A protein that can go on to
serve some function in the cell that
process DNA transcribed to RNA and then
translated into protein forms what many
of us know as the central dogma of
biology it is beautiful it is elegant
and it is also far too simplistic for
what life actually looks like there are
many ways that process is more
complicated than what we originally said
but we're here for the kinetoplastids
and their strange DNA chain mail
one of the unusual things researchers in
the 1980s noticed as they studied
kinetoplast DNA is that there were genes
that almost coded for things we knew
they should code for the sequences in
them created instructions that looked
like they should make a particular
protein found in these organisms but
something would just be off mutations
would shift the instructions slightly
almost as if they were missing key words
or someone had deleted a step in the
instruction manual but that was in the
DNA when they studied the RNA the
instructions were suddenly correct again
almost as if they had been edited to
make sense in fact that's what the
researchers would call the process RNA
editing this process turned up over and
over again in the kinetoplastids
nonsensical instructions in the DNA
would make sense later thanks to RNA
editing a biological process poking at
the person reading from the manual to
correct their final message
kinetoplasts aren't the only organisms
to use RNA editing and it's not quite
clear what advantages there are to the
process perhaps it allows a single Gene
to encode multiple proteins perhaps it's
a necessary adaptation to contend with
mutations or perhaps it's some other
explanation we don't even know enough to
imagine now autonids are not the only
microbes that Force us to re-evaluate
the fundamentals microbes are constantly
showing us different ways to do the
basics and inspiring new techniques in
the process tools like crispr are rooted
in this kind of reevaluation this
expansion and complication of our dogmas
this is usually the point in an episode
where I want to end by sighing and
saying all that in this organism is just
living its life it doesn't know because
that is sometimes what it feels like
hundreds of words about this invisible
process very deep in this funny
flagellated creature that doesn't know
what we're even talking about it doesn't
know why we've spent all this time
looking at it and studying it and even
if it did would it really care it has a
whole life to live a life that will
continue long after I'm done talking
about RNA editing and we will never get
to know what the entirety of that life
is only that it involves chainmail made
of DNA Circles of information linked
together to produce questions we will
chase forever
thank you thank you for coming on this
journey with us as we explore the Unseen
World that surrounds us and thank you to
nordvpn for supporting this episode
nordvpn takes Internet safety seriously
and you should too nordvpn provides you
a secure encrypted tunnel for your
online traffic to flow through nobody
can see through the tunnel get their
hands on your online data or find your
real IP address and location now when
you're working out of your local coffee
shop and are worried about joining that
sketchy looking free customer Wi-Fi
network you can have peace of mind and
securely access personal information or
work files encrypt your internet
connection and keep your browsing
history and online identity private
enjoy online privacy and security with
nordvpn they have super fast servers in
over 60 countries and they have 24 7
customer support with live chat or email
and right now for a limited time you can
get an exclusive two-year plan with one
month free and a special gift if you go
to nordvpn.com
microcosmos and use code microcosmos
it's risk-free with nord's 30-day
money-back guarantee and that link again
is nordvpn.com
microcosmos the link is in the
description
the names on the screen right now are
our patreon patrons some of the people
who have decided to directly support
this channel over at patreon.com journey
to micro without them our Channel could
not exist so we want to say thank you to
all of them if you want to see more from
our master of microscopes James Weiss
you can check out jam and germs on
Instagram and Tick Tock and you can also
find Journey to the microcosmos on Tick
Tock now if you want some micro micro
Cosmos a couple times a week and if you
want to see more from us here on YouTube
there is always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
foreign